Okay,
yes.
What is your opinion on the whole
cultural appropriate?
Okay,
two questions.
What's my opinion on the alt right and
what's my opinion on cultural
appropriation?
The idea of cultural appropriation is
absolute nonsense.
That's that.
No,
there's no difference between cultural
appropriation and learning from one
another.
The same thing.
Now that doesn't mean I can't.
That doesn't mean that there's no theft
between people.
There is no.
It doesn't mean that just because you
encounter someone else's ideas,
you have an immediate right to those
ideas as if they were your own,
but the idea that manifesting in your
own behavior,
some element of another culture,
the idea that that's somehow immoral is
insane.
It's actually one of the bases of peace.
You know,
one of the things that the various
groups of human beings that exist have
to offer each other is the tremendous
value of their culture.
You know,
it's been really interesting to me,
for example,
to watch the response of ball of
everyone,
but for this argument to you,
for young Caucasian males to hip hop,
you know,
there's an aggressiveness about hip hop
that's really attractive to young
Caucasian males and there's something
observed about,
about the,
the spectacle of the young Caucasian
males taking on the persona of inner
city black gang members,
you know,
but,
but I'm sympathetic to it because there
is an aggressiveness to that,
to that art form that's a necessary
corrective to the insistence that the
highest moral virtue for a modern man is
harmlessness,
which is observed.
Women don't even like harmless man.
They hate them.
They liked them apart.